the Justice Department's internal
watchdog is set to release a highly
anticipated report on whether the FBI
conducted illegal surveillance of the
Trump campaign back in 2016
President Trump tweeted the report will
be today's big story
he's accused the FBI and the Justice
Department have been proper spying
calling the investigation of his
campaign a witch-hunt for the first time
on CBS this morning we welcome senior
investigative correspondent there she is
Catherine Harridge who's at the Justice
Department Catherine first welcome to
the team good morning to you what do you
expect the report to find well Gail I am
so proud to join a team that puts
original reporting first CBS News has
learned a former FBI lawyer is under
criminal investigation for allegedly
altering a record related to the 2016
surveillance warrant the nearly two year
probe by Justice Department Inspector
General Michael Horowitz review of more
than 1 million records and conducted
more than 100 witness interviews while
the report is expected to harshly
criticize the FBI Horowitz may also
conclude the bureau had enough evidence
to initiate the nearly year-long secret
surveillance for Carter page the FBI
suspected the former Trump campaign
adviser was helping Russia medley' in
the 2016 election in 2018 former FBI
director James Comey told house
investigators that he had no concerns
about the surveillance for an
application and three subsequent
renewals on Sunday Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham who called Horowitz to
publicly later testify this week said he
expects the findings to be jamming
adding Comey support of the surveillance
warrant would not withstand scrutiny and
anyone who misled the court should face
consequences Republicans hope a strong
report will allow them to punch back as
we near votes on the articles of
impeachment a mixed reporter week
findings would allow Democrats to refute
mr. Trump's claims that the Russia
investigation was a hoax Anthony we
await that report Catherine thank you
very much